frequentava la prima media
in una mattina entra in classe
l'insegnante di musica aveva una
chitarra in mano si sedette sopra la
cattedra ed iniziò a suonare e noi
alunni incominciamo a cantare insieme a
lui non so che cosa accadde in quel
momento ma come un colpo di fulmine
nacque dentro di me il desiderio di fare
musica
anch'io volevo suonare la chitarra e
fare quello che faceva lui e vi assicuro
che non ero mosso dal desiderio di
conquiste femminili
fu un qualcosa di inaspettato anche
perché nella mia famiglia
nessuno suonava uno strumento musicale e
io assolutamente non ci avevo mai
pensato prima di allora prima di quel
momento
fatto sta che per natale quell'anno mi
feci regalare una chitarra e dani è
cominciato il percorso che mi ha portato
ad essere quello che sono oggi quando
sono stato invitato all'evento di oggi a
questo evento mi sono interrogato molto
su ciò di cui gli avrei potuto parlare
sappiamo che il tema è il cambiamento e
anche la musica negli ultimi anni ha
subito delle profonde trasformazioni
pensiamo solamente che in un arco di
tempo piuttosto ristretto siamo passati
dall ascoltare la musica da un disco di
vinile fino allo streaming digitale
itunes spotify youtube
penso andando un pochino più indietro
nel tempo ma neanche troppo penso ai
miei nonni che magari si sono conosciuti
in una balera
penso che oggi la musica la si ascolti
negli stadi con un numero veramente
importante di persone
penso che però alla musica la possiamo
anche ascoltare stando comodamente
seduti sul divano guardando per esempio
un talent show insomma ci sono
tantissimi spunti
tuttavia ho pensato e ho deciso di
ribaltare un attimino il mio punto di
vista sul concetto di cambiamento quindi
anziché a raccontarvi qualcosa su come
la musica sia cambiata
mi piacerebbe raccontarvi qualcosa su
come la musica ci può cambiare la musica
ha cambiato la mia vita in meglio
penso che possa farlo anche per le
vostre vite per ognuno di voi
ognuno di noi
immagino che abbia una canzone del cuore
una musica che quando l'ascolta riporta
al suo pensiero ad una persona
determinata situazione
sarà capitato a tutti di ascoltare una
canzone una radio un cd per darsi un po
di carica o magari al contrario per
cercare un po di relax
questo è uno degli aspetti più potenti
della musica quello di poterci riportare
in un istante ad uno stato d'animo
differente rispetto a quello in cui ci
troviamo
uno studio ha rivelato attraverso delle
scansioni dell'attività cerebrale che su
soggetti a cui viene fatta ascoltare la
musica nel cervello di queste persone si
sviluppa un fenomeno molto interessante
sono tantissime le zone che vengono
stimolate e addirittura i ricercatori
che hanno condotto questo esperimento
hanno paragonato quello che accedevano
succedeva alla corteccia cerebrale di
queste persone come uno spettacolo
pirotecnico i fuochi d'artificio nella
testa di chi ascolta la musica
un'evoluzione di questo studio ha
inoltre rivelato che questo spettacolo
pirotecnico questi fuochi d'artificio
diventano ancora più dinamici ed
interessanti nella testa di chi la
musica la fa suonando quindi dei
musicisti voglio darvi un consiglio
regalatevi e regalate uno strumento
musicale ad una persona a cui volete
bene potete regalarlo alla vostra
compagna alla vostra moglie o ancora
meglio a qualcuno di più giovane ai
vostri figli ai vostri nipoti può
sicuramente migliorare la qualità della
vostra vita
cominciamo sfatando un primo mito gli
strumenti musicali non sono cari non
hanno un prezzo proibitivo esiste tutta
una fascia di mercato in cui si trovano
degli strumenti dedicati ai principianti
che hanno dei costi decisamente
accessibili
penso che l'ultimo smartphone che ci
siamo regalati sia sicuramente più caro
di uno strumento musicale per
principianti
non dobbiamo poi dimenticare tra l'altro
che ognuno di noi è naturalmente dotato
di uno strumento musicale che è la voce
che si può esprimere e si può utilizzare
per fare musica attraverso il canto un
secondo mito da sfatare è che fare
musica non è complicato e complicato
diventare dei professionisti ma questo
richiede chiaramente studio dedizione e
impegno raggiungere invece un buon
livello amatoriale è decisamente alla
portata di tutti noi
voglio elencarvi quelli che secondo me
sono alcuni dei benefici più importanti
che lo studio della musica e di uno
strumento ci possa regalare vi renderete
conto ascoltandomi di quanto possano
essere straordinariamente formativi per
ognuno di noi e di quanto possano essere
formativi soprattutto per i più giovani
per i ragazzi e per gli adolescenti
lo studio di uno strumento musicale
innanzitutto migliora la propria
capacità di organizzazione pianificare
un percorso di studio attraverso una
serie di brani di difficoltà crescente
equivale a darsi degli obiettivi
la cosa straordinaria è che ogni volta
che voi conquistate un obiettivo detto
in soldoni ogni volta che imparato a
suonare una canzone nuova avrete una
gratificazione immediata e tangibile
peraltro il metodo di studio che si usa
nella musica può essere un modello
efficace ed esportabile in altre
attività della nostra vita per
raggiungere altri obiettivi e decidiamo
di imporci nella nostra vita
lo studio della musica migliora la
gestione del proprio tempo
sappiamo tutti quanti che le nostre
giornate sono fittissime di impegni che
possono essere impegni lavorativi
impegni familiari possono essere impegni
scolastici per i più giovani e sappiamo
anche che riuscire a ricavare un po di
tempo per noi stessi è molto complicato
lo studio di uno strumento ovviamente
presuppone un tot di ore di allenamento
anzi la soluzione ottimale sarebbe
quella di riuscire a ricavare in ognuna
delle nostre giornate
una piccola sessione di pratica di
studio questo sembra molto complicato ma
nella realtà vi posso assicurare che se
si accende la fiamma della passione per
la musica per lo strumento dentro ognuno
di voi si possono fare miracoli
in questo senso vi porto un esempio tra
i miei allievi
c'è un ragazzo che ha un impiego come
direttore di banca e del padre di
famiglia quindi potrete facilmente
immaginare quali siano gli impegni della
sua vita di come possa essere fitta la
sua vita è bene lui per poter studiare
la chitarra
tutte le mattine si sveglia un'ora prima
per non sottrarre tempo né alla famiglia
e al suo lavoro
a lui va tutta la mia stima e penso che
sia un ottimo esempio rispetto a quello
che vi dicevo poc'anzi correlato a
questo concetto c'è un miglioramento
della capacità di concentrazione
se il tempo che hai per studiare e poco
devi imparare a farlo rendere al meglio
sarebbe stupido rosicchiare del tempo
alle attività della nostra vita per
dedicare allo strumento è poi così
distrarsi e buttarlo via
bisogna imparare a non cedere alle
distrazioni che è l'unico modo per non
rendere vano il proprio impegno
un'altra cosa che ci può insegnare la
pratica musicale è il lavoro in team
una delle esperienze più belle che un
musicista possa fare e condividere la
propria musica con altri musicisti
regala delle grandissime soddisfazioni
la pratica della musica d'assieme
attraverso uno spartito ti fa capire
immediatamente
qual è il tuo ruolo all'interno
dell'insieme di insegna ad ascoltare gli
altri a cooperare con loro
e a seguire le indicazioni di un
direttore d'orchestra quando c'è un
direttore dell'esecuzione e grazie alle
tue orecchie riesce a rendersi
immediatamente conto che è soltanto
attraverso una precisa ed equilibrata
cooperazione che si possono raggiungere
i risultati migliori
lo studio della musica e la musica
d'insieme nello specifico tra l'altro
possono anche aiutarci a sviluppare
delle relazioni interpersonali
nel momento in cui ci si trova a fare
parte di un gruppo di persone che sono
legate da un interesse comune e che
lavorano tutti quanti
nella stessa direzione si crea un
terreno fertile per sviluppare per
esempio delle altre conoscenze
io credo di essere l'esempio lampante di
tutto questo io sono una persona
estremamente introversa e timida e
grazie alla musica ho coltivato alcune
delle più importanti amicizie della mia
vita
peraltro non soltanto con altri
musicisti ma anche con persone che
magari sono venute ad ascoltarmi mentre
suonavo e tra l'altro è fantastico poi
poter pensare che attraverso il
linguaggio della musica si possa
comunicare un qualche cosa ad una
persona che non conosci e che da qui poi
addirittura possa svilupparsi un
rapporto penso che sia una magia
straordinaria
infine lo studio della musica può essere
molto utile per vincere la timidezza
spero possa capitare a tutti coloro che
decideranno di accostarsi al mondo e la
musica di poter fare un concerto
il primo concerto
è il momento in cui scopri che cos'è
l'ansia da prestazione
nel momento in cui tu sali sul
palcoscenico e senti esattamente come se
fossi nudo davanti a una platea di
persone che ti stanno guardando
ora a prescindere da come possa andare
questo concerto innanzitutto è traguardo
molto importante di caricare di
adrenalina e ti farà venire la voglia di
farne tanti altri concerto dopo concerto
le cose ovviamente miglioreranno si
diventerà sempre più bravi e questo fa
crescere la tua autostima e la tua
autostima fa scomparire quella
sensazione di nudità di cui vi parlavo
poc'anzi
a quel punto poi pian piano riuscirai
sempre di più a concentrarti sul tuo
messaggio e quindi lascerei fuori tutti
questi problemi
se questa fosse una bugia peraltro io
oggi non potrei essere qua su questo
tappeto rosso a parlare con voi
ogni tanto mi domando come sarebbe la
mia vita oggi se quel giorno della prima
media non fosse entrato l'insegnante con
la chitarra in mano a farci cantare ma
fosse entrato che sono un vecchio
bacchettone non so se sarebbe avvenuto
comunque il mio incontro con la musica
non so se si può dare una risposta a
tutto questo io in ogni caso sono
felicissimo che sia andata così perché
lo ripeto credo fermamente che la musica
abbia fatto di me una persona migliore è
peraltro non posso che essere
riconoscente ai miei genitori che mi
hanno sempre supportato ed incoraggiato
in questo cammino
in fondo se non fosse per la musica io
nuovamente non potrei essere qua a
condividere qualcosa con voi e a
raccontarvi qualche cosa essere qua per
me peraltro è un grandissimo onore e vi
ringrazio per avermi ascoltato
umberto se il ragazzo